northern boroughs have been shaped by
many influences in the past and various
shaping processes continue to this day
there is more to the borough's than a
first glance may suggest
the famous pebble rich provides the
Burroughs with a protective wall
the rich faces Northwest to be incessant
searches of the Atlantic
the pebble Ridge finally turns west and
ends in the estuary where the tall and
taurus rivers join to meet the sea a
great bite in the estuary is occupied by
the skin mud flats
thus kern is of vital importance as a
wintering grind for migrant birds in
front of the scone are the deep waters
of Appledore Poole the lifeboat is
moored here an apple door itself is a
fishing village at the mouth of the
Touareg in Stowe faces Appledore across
the river at the southern end of the
Burroughs is westward ho the seaside
resort
and between Westwood her in the south
and Appledore in the north the landward
border of the boroughs lies at the foot
of the ancient hill settlement of
northern hundreds of years ago the
boroughs was a place for farming rabbits
that's how it got its name few people
managed to spot them these days but
there are still some living there
you
the boroughs is common land and
residents of the manor of northern have
traditional rights to graze their sheep
and horses here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the grazing animals wander over the
whole area but the site has several
types of terrain the least attractive is
probably the area immediately behind the
pebble Ridge but this provides important
overspill parking for recreation on the
burrows or on the beach
there is an area of rough pasture at the
Westwood hoe end but in winter it is so
waterlogged that birds prefer it to dog
walkers beyond that the central section
of the burrows is dominated by the golf
course
you
at the end of the central road next to
the sea is sandy Muir a seasonal lake
here too
is the visitors center and easy parking
and access to the beach
a fence helps to protect the small area
of sand dunes which is very important
for wildlife
Rush's and scrub dominate the landscape
increasingly as you move northwards and
rough grind eventually takes over
completely from the golf course
there is a lot of marshy land at the
eastern edge and here there is a
watercourse known as the pill it
stretches across most of the boroughs
most of the time it is just draining the
land but on the highest tides it becomes
filled up completely towards Appledore a
road has been built up making a
retaining wall to the mud flats
it was originally constructed to serve
the landfill site but is now a great
asset to visitors there is parking along
it and at the end
the carpark gives very convenient access
to gray Suns
Graysons has been greatly modified by
use as a landfill site in the recent
past but is now restored to nature the
central fenced area of the old dump is
out of bounds but this enables wildlife
to flourish their gray sands has its own
special character from grace ants there
are fine views of the river scenery and
across to the huge and famous Brunton
burrows Sand Hill system
it is certainly a place worth heading
for
we've looked briefly at the shape of the
burrows now we will focus on some of the
forces which do the shaping of them all
none can be greater than the relentless
sea summer and winter it pounds and
sucks the petal ridge trying to claim
the burrows for its own
most of the time the pebble Ridge is an
effective barrier separating the burrows
from the beach but at the highest tides
and in stormy weather the sea throws
pebbles and debris onto the land beyond
seeking to flatten the ridge where the
ridge is weakest it breaks open gaps and
inundates the land beyond
worst of all where the ridge has all but
disappeared it directly attacks the
unprotected base of the sand dunes
themselves tens or scores of meters of
this value habitat are lost to the sea
each year
and part of the golf course are also
under threat or have already been lost
the need to repair the destructive work
of the waves or to reinforce defenses is
exhausting and unending the fence around
the conservation area needs to be moved
steadily inland by the Burroughs Rangers
as each year storms carry way more land
on the seaward side
meanwhile large earthmoving machinery is
needed to repair the ridge where the
golf course is most at threat or were
the underlying landfill material is at
risk of being exposed
[Music]
[Music]
vegetation may colonize the rebuilt
Ridge during the summer but each winter
the defenses are likely to be thrown
down again
but although the sea is such a
destructive force it is the very same
waves which make the country Park such a
delight to so many
summer aunt winter the waves offer an
attractive playground
for some the frequent strong winds are
an adage drawer
and apart from the sea itself the wide
clean sandy beach is a huge attraction
adding to the allure of this country
park
as soon as the sound is uncovered
someone is keen to get onto it dogs are
banned from the Westwood hoe and during
summer but they make the most of it
whenever they can't get to the beach
[Music]
all year round the beach is a wonderful
playground for people as well as dogs
and is the perfect place to relax and
unwind
[Music]
all summer long the beach is well
protected by lifeguards both at Westwood
ho and at Sandy Muir
[Music]
the spacious sandy beach is an ideal
place for those who are learning to surf
to develop their skills it is much used
by local surf schools and scan Lodge
activity center
whether you are in the water or just
looking at it
Westwood her was a great place to spend
a few hours on a summer day
the sea directly challenges the pebble
Ridge but the rising tide also influence
other areas
as it creeps up reclaiming the shore it
drives the birds from the estuary
feeding grinds where the very tail of
the pebble ridge plunges into the deep
river channel at the edge of the mud
flats the incoming tide may bring fish
upstream this is always a popular site
for anglers the lifeboat at its mooring
swings around to face into the strong
flowing tide the scone has been a
glistening expanse of mud flats for many
hours but now the tide creeps back over
it
[Music]
the feeding birds are pushed further and
further up Shore concentrated into a
smaller area in winter these can form
huge mixed flocks many will now just sit
and wait for the tide to turn
[Music]
on the highest heights called the spring
tight twice a month the river pushes
high enough to enter the mouth of the
pill
the rising water flows under the
Appledore bridge sometimes to fill the
channel beyond
on the very highest tides it may
inundate some of the adjoining land then
footpaths become streams and damp eras
of vegetation become thoroughly soaked
the Sheep must find an escape route to
trier grind
[Music]
[Music]
but without these inundations the
variety of the borough's would suffer
damp loving plants need it for building
of the scone Road of the long since
changed the nature of the land so that
much of it is drier and more scrubby
than it used to be with the rising of
the tide the river comes into its own
there is usually plenty to watch it is a
popular place for recreational sailing
weather racing or more leisurely work
boats still go about their business as
they always did
Lundy's supply ship the Oldenburg will
often be seen passing weather on a
stores run or loaded with passengers in
summer
and often the gig oarsmen from Apple
tour will be C night practicing
you fishing boats ply their trade
several types of crafts are operated by
the Royal Marines who use the estuary as
a training grind to practice their
skills
[Music]
and some quite large ships still come
and go the river is very rarely boring
water changes to face
the country park considerably during the
cycle of seasons the accumulation of
rain lying on water sodden ground
creates seasonal Lakes
of these sandy Mir is the most
conspicuous lying just behind the pebble
ridge an overspill car park at sometimes
at others it is a brackish lake of
considerable extent
[Music]
another area which changes from
pastureland
to an inland lake is that just below the
landfill mound whether it is used by
sheep and dog walkers or by water birds
depends on the season
[Music]
one of the most obvious human forces to
have shaped northern boroughs is surely
the golf club the Royal North Devon golf
club was founded in 1864 and is the
oldest Golf Course in England it must
surely have one of the very best
settings of any golf course it is
regarded as a tough course and is ranked
in the top 100 of the world's golf
courses it is plain that many of the
undulations in the landscape are where
the Golf Course has tamed the underlying
sand dunes the bunkers and greens add
variety to the scenery under tended
fairways also create an attractive
contrast to the wild landscapes amongst
which they are laid
winter and summer the course is always
popular
undoubtedly the borough's would be a
less attractive place without the
variety which the golf course adds to
the Vista Golf is the recreation which
has had the most obvious visual impact
on the country park but many visitors
enjoy other types of recreation there
also some like just to relax
usually choosing the best viewpoints but
walking usually with dogs is undoubtedly
the most popular recreation of all dogs
and people enjoy the spacious sands when
the tide is out but the burrows can be
used at all states of the tide the broad
riverbanks and water sculptured sands of
the estuary have their own particular
attractiveness
others enjoy the sight and sound of the
multitudes of wild birds the pressure of
people and dogs does have an impact on
the park but thankfully most visitors
show respect and consideration
towards both grazing animals and wild
birds there are only a few sad
exceptions which cause panic and
distress the burros includes part of the
South West Coast path
and at the scone end of the Burroughs
there is a dedicated area for horse
riding the Burroughs is quite popular
with job is to surely be a much more
uplifting way of exercising than
pounding a treadmill indoors the variety
and beauty of the landscape of northern
boroughs is further enhanced by the
weather and the seasons and by the
corresponding changes in the natural
world
[Music]
[Music]
not surprisingly this little country
park in our corner of north devon is
listed as an SSI a Site of Special
Scientific Interest
[Music]
[Music]
it deserves to be better known and
appreciated and to be protected and
nurtured for future generations it
repays time spent in getting to know it
and deserves to be better known and
appreciated and to be safeguarded and
enhanced for the years to come